Welcome back everyone
Maximum effort!
Marvel has a brand new video of Deadpool
3 of Wolverine
versus Deadpool on that void Planet
from the Loki series.
And we just got the Loki season
two trailer,
which has a bunch of Easter eggs for
what's happening during Deadpool three.
So we'll break it all down
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe
to get all the episodes.
Loki Season two
will be coming in October, but Ahsoka
episodes will be coming before that.
All due videos for everything.
There's a lot of really big stuff
coming up.
the scene as Deadpool and Wolverine
fighting each other
in front of the remnants of the 20th
Century Fox logo on the Void planet.
The joke being that Fox got prude
at some point in a meta commentary
on Disney buying out Fox Marvel,
getting all the X-Men Fantastic
Four characters back. recasting everyone.
So they're clowning on metaphor
that the old X-Men movies and all the Fox
Marvel movies for that matter, don't
really matter that much anymore because
Marvel is making new ones
that are canon to the MCU.
So they're getting rid
of all the old stuff
That was kind of the point
of the Void planet.
It was the stuff that they pruned
that they sent to this place
at the end of time that they didn't
want to deal with anymore.
the real reason that he who remains king
created the void planet,
though, was to prune
all the dangerous variants that would lead
to the rise of dangerous versions
of Kang, dangerous versions of himself.
that was the whole secret
of the Void planet.
Like all the different Loki's,
there were meant to be so different
that they led to the rise of dangerous
Kang variants.
So like anything that was out of place
that would lead to the rise of a dangerous
Kang got put there.
So like the pyramids
from the Rama version of Kang
apparently in whichever
Fox Marvel universe that this Fox
logo came from, there was a dangerous
Kang variant that rose up there
there were some Easter eggs
for the Rama version of Kang
during X-Men Apocalypse because Apocalypse
as backstory crosses over
with the Rama version of Kang.
But because of the way
the copyright issues
worked between the Fox
Marvel movies in the MCU, Marvel movies,
I don't think that Fox actually
had the rights to do the Kang character
in any of their movies.
Originally what happened
is that Rama was the first persona
that Kang created for himself.
He went to the distant past
to try and rule.
Eventually he just got bored of it
after he fought the fantastic for their
When he escaped to the future,
that's when he created the Kang
the Conqueror persona
and then came back to the past
to fight the Avengers over and over again.
But when he left the distant past
in ancient Egypt, he actually left
everything to apocalypse
and set him up as his successor.
at the beginning of X-Men Apocalypse
it just means that
that has already happened.
Like there's already been a version
of Romita Kang
that has passed everything
on to Apocalypse in reality,
what Kevin Vega is doing now
is they are recasting some new versions
of the X-Men characters, Fantastic
Four characters, but some of them
will continue, like Reynolds
Deadpool will continue.
some of the classic X-Men actors
will also be back again for Avengers
six Secret Wars, like Hugh Jackman's
Wolverine will be back
because of the multiverse of it all.
It's going to be sort of like a swan song
for all the classic Fox Marvel movies,
not just the classic X-Men movies,
but the Fantastic Four movies, even
Ben Affleck's Daredevil, all that stuff.
that's why there are
so many of those cameos in Deadpool three.
Like I've already done videos about Chris
Evans coming back as Human Torch
from the Fantastic Four movies,
Ben Affleck coming back as his daredevil.
Even Jennifer Garner is coming back
as her version of Elektra from the Ben
Affleck Daredevil movie.
some of those cameos
will be bigger than others.
Like it's more of an X-Men movie
than it is like a Daredevil Ben Affleck
kind of movie.
So his scenes will probably be
pretty short
compared to the classic X-Men actors
that are coming back.
very apropos.
Kahui Kuan,
who is now in the MCU through Loki Season
two is this character was also working
on the first X-Men movie.
This is him
working with Hugh Jackman's Wolverine.
the circle of Easter eggs is now complete.
but the other thing
that this scene confirms is that Deadpool
and Wolverine have been pruned by the TVA
at some point in the movie
because Deadpool has been jumping around
with cable's time travel device, causing
a whole bunch of nexus events,
destabilizing the multiverse even more.
then they just have it out with each other
hacking away
because Wolverine can't stand Deadpool.
That's why the logo had him
swiping his claws through Deadpool symbol.
But the joke is
that they both have healing factors.
So the fight goes on forever
since they keep instantly
healing the damage
and eventually they just get bored
of hacking away bits of each other
and have to come together
to find a way to escape the void planet.
Just like Loki
and Sylvie did during Loki season one.
during the Loki Season
two trailer, we also see Ren Slayer,
who escaped at the end of season one.
Back on that void planet
witnessing something.
So at some point she has to escape
the void planet to Normally when stuff
got sent to the void planet,
he who remains king would have alliance
just consume them in obliterate them
from all of existence.
sort of like a cosmic trash compactor
that was capable of consuming
entire universes.
we'll
see what they explain happened to Alliance
after the end of season one.
Because if he who remains king
was the one that found and controlled him
and sent him to the Void planet,
then maybe that didn't happen.
In this new version of the timeline
we actually see the remains,
like literally the body of he
who remains at the end of Loki season
one during the Loki season two trailer.
I think they just have that
the beginning of the season to address
what happens next after that moment.
the people we know that are coming back
from the Loki series in Deadpool three,
or at least Mobius and Miss Minutes,
they'll be some new TVA characters
who aren't in Loki.
Season two, like Matthew McFayden
from Succession is supposed to be the TVA.
Agent Mobius in Science,
the Deadpool's case.
His name is meant to be Paradox,
during the Loki season two
trailer K who he can
is kind of like the tech guy for the TVA.
His office is literally in the bottom
level of the TVA in his name is Örebro,
so they all have time themed names
Emma Corrin is supposed to be a TVA judge
who sentences Deadpool
and I'm not expecting Loki himself to show
up, but we'll see.
There might be some Deadpool
three Post-Credits scenes
at the end of Loki season two,
or just some Deadpool Easter eggs
There's a lot of conflicting reports
about what the timeline is for all this.
Like if Deadpool three comes
after Loki season two or before it
and it might come before it
because in the Loki Season two
trailer, you see them inspecting the raw
timeline itself.
and it looks like time itself
is unraveling like a rope unraveling,
which means that time itself is coming
apart, like time is being destroyed
slowly from the back to the front,
when we see Loki glitching out.
There was a similar effect in Ant-Man
and the WASP Quantumania where it looked
like some of the Ant-Man
versions were literally unraveling
Mobius. Wow.
Great to see you again.
That.
That's what's been happening.
Wow. Time slipping where you times.
You know that? Yeah.
You've seen that?
Yeah. Can you fix that? No.
It's impossible to be in the TVA.
I know, but we just saw it happen.
Now, this isn't meant to be
the exact same thing as glitching
during Spider-Man across the Spider-Verse
it's a little bit different.
Glitching is the result of someone
from a different universe
being in the wrong universe.
all the TVA
agents are meant to be variants,
so they're all different versions
in the wrong universe.
And we've seen them
walking around in other universes
being just fine and not glitching.
So even though what's happening to Loki
here looks similar to what's happening
in across the Spider-Verse, it's
not the exact same thing.
but Deadpool three is adapting
a version of Deadpool kills the Marvel
Universe, the joke being that he's
killing the Fox Marvel universe,
causing a bunch of incursions,
destabilizing the multiverse even more in.
According to Kevin Feige.
It's a big tipping point
for the multiverse
heading up to Avengers five, Qing Dynasty.
Avengers
six Secret Wars with all the incursions
The idea is that they have a version
of the Kang Multiverse War
get like a big on screen $300
million version during Avengers five in
that leads to the destruction of all
the remaining universes till the very end.
They actually combine
the remnants into a single universe,
single planet battle world.
And that's Avengers six Secret Wars.
so what might be happening is that during
Loki season one, Sylvie kills
he who remains freeing the wider
multiverse to rise,
leading to a bunch of evil
king variants coming back,
starting a new Kang Multiverse war
that begins to destabilize the multiverse
with all the different kings
destroying other universes, then doctor.
Strange causes more incursions
during multiverse of madness,
destabilizing things a little bit more
things continue to get worse.
Then Deadpool three comes along.
He wrecks the multiverse way way worse,
leading to the damage you see
to the timeline here in Loki Season two.
so time itself breaking coming
apart at the seams isn't solely because
of what Sylvie did.
It's the sum total of all the damage
all these different Marvel
characters have been doing across
Marvel Phase four Mobile Phase five.
In addition to the Kang Multiverse War.
that all just culminate in Avengers
five Qing Dynasty.
I've already talked about Wolverine's
yellow costume.
It's based a little bit
more on the astonishing X-Men version,
but it's based on a reality
which might wind up being the 838 reality.
Like they might wind up going back there
and turning that into a house of M reality
I think that's why all the X-Men
that are coming back are meant to look
so much more comic book
accurate to those classic costumes.
that's how they're avoiding
completely Retconning the events of Logan
in some of the other Fox Marvel movies,
like it's a completely different timeline
where Deadpool finds this
version of Wolverine,
who's a slightly younger version
of the character than we saw during Logan.
supposedly, though, they're actually going
to be pulling in Ant-Man
and the WASP Quantumania joke line
where you saw the Army of Mad
Like an Army of Ants,
but it's an army of Ant-Man.
They'll be doing a similar thing
with Deadpool three,
with a bunch of different Deadpool
variants in a bunch of Wolverine variants
that might be something that happens
because of what they're doing on the Void
planet here,
because they did that joke
during Loki season
one where you have a bunch of different
Loki's, that's where Deadpool
would find a bunch of different
Deadpool variants
in a bunch of different Wolverine
variants.
I'm not going to hold my breath
or anything, but it would be hilarious
if they actually show us a Deadpool
like some weird Ryan Reynolds
Deadpool variant at some point
during Loki season two
while someone is on the Void Planet
if you spotted any other Easter eggs
or references
in any of the footage in the video,
just write it below in the comments.
We'll get more teasers and trailers
later this year and we get a soak episodes
in a couple of weeks.
So be sure to enable all my channels
so you don't miss any of that stuff.
Click here for my full Loki Season
two trailer video and click here for that
brand new Ahsoka trailer video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe.
Maximum effort!